ايضا في هذا الملف ومعنى من اسطنبول ايضا
مرسل العربيه زميل زيدان زينكو اولا زيدان
يعني ما الجديد الذي لديك حتى الان نتحدث
عن سته قتلى و81 مصابا لكن الانباء التي
رشحت قبل قليل بانو هناك اثنان من بين
المصابين حالتهم حاله ما اخر المعلومات
التي لديك حول هذا الموضوع
نعم اسامه من بين المصابين هناك حوالي 42
شخص ما زالوا يتلقون العلاج 5 في العنايه
المركزه اثنان من الخمسه ما زالوا في حاله
خطره همم وبالتا الى قدر الله ان همم هناك
احتماليه لارتفاع عدد ضحايا لكن حتى الان
الحصيله النهائيه سته قتله و81 مصاب فانا
اقرا هنا همم عند مدخل شارع الاستقلال في
ميدان تقسيم كما تشاهد خلفي الشارع فارغ
تماما من المره همم الشرطه ما زالت تتواجد
في المكان وايضا عناصر من الهلال الاحمر
التركي همم
نرى هذا يعني على الهواء مباشره
باتجاه شارع الاستقلال كما نشاهد همم في
عمق الشارع او لا ادري اذا كانت الكاميرا
تستطيع ان تصرصد همم هناك همم همم حافله
للشرطه وبعض سيارات الشرطه وعناصر الشرطه
من يتواجدون في داخل همم شارع الاستقلال
الشارع مغلق تماما همم امام الماره وحتى
امام اصحاب المحاله الذين اغلقوا محالهم
بعد وقوع الانفجار بطلب من الشرطه الشوارع
المحيطه في شارع الاستقلال تشهد حريق حركه
همم نوعا ما قليل لكن هناك محل هناك محل
ايضا ما زالت تفتح ابوابها امام
السياح او حتى سكان هذه المنطقه لكن في
الشوارع المحيطه من شارع الاستقلال اما
شارع الاستقلال ما زال مغلقه ساعه
الانفجار وحتى هذه اللحظه همم طبعا همم
كما اعلن همم الرئيس التركي والرئيس
التركي ان امراه همم تقف خلف هذا الانفجار
نائب رئيس تركي ان همم قال ان التفجير
ناجم عن همم قنبله فجرتها امراه دون ان
يعطي اي تفاصيل اضافيه عن جنسيه هذه
الامراه او حتى
كيف حصلت على هذه القنبله حتى الان
السلطات التركيه والتحديدا السلطات
الامنيه تتكتم عن اي معلومات لها علاقه في
موضوع التفجير بانتظار استكمال التحقيقات
على ما يبدو في ظل حضر فرضترضه المجلس
الاعلى للاذاعه والتلفزيون على وسائل
الاعلام للنشر اي همم خبر يتعلق في هذا
الموضوع موضوع التفجير باستثناء المعلومات
الرسميه التي يدلي بها بين الفين والاخرى
مسؤولون اتراك ايضا هناك حظر على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي من نشر اي معلومات
سلبيه همم تتعلق بهذا الموضوع وتسمى همم
سيتم ملاحقه كما تم الاعلان عنه قبل قليل
همم 25 او اشخاص همم 25 حساب على وجه
التحديد نشره همم منشورات استفزازيه كما
قالت السلطات التركيه عبر وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي هناك تقيد لوصول لبعض منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي تويتر لمنع اي همم
اخبار او صور همم ما الذي تعني
همم
ما الذي يعني زيدان يعني عبارات استفزازيه
هل هي يعني مؤيده للتفجير مثلا ام ماذا
بالظبط ام صور ضحايا ام ماذا بالضبط
لم يتم التوضيح هذه النقطه لكن هذا البيان
فقط الذي جاء لكن بالعموم اي منشورات
سلبيه سواء عن الضحايا او ربما تعليقات
همم تؤيد على الانفجار او ربما تدلي
بمعلومات كاذبه عن موضوع الانفجار هذا
الموضوع سيتم ملاحقته من قبل السلطات
التركيه همم لذلك هناك تجديد على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي لعدم نشر اي معلومات
تتعلق بهذا التفجير همم طبعا همم الحظر هو
مؤقت بطبيعه الحال وهو ليس الاول من نوعه
الذي تشاهده تركيا
في عده مناسبات همم تفجيرات سابقه واحداث
ارهابيه سابقه تم حظر ان نشر المؤقت من
قبل همم المجلس الاعلى للتلفزيون الراديو
والتليفزيون في تركيا اشكرك شكرا جزيلا
بالتاكيد سنظل نتابع معك كل ما هو جديد من
هذا بعد هذا الحادث باشكرك شكرا جزيلا كنت
معنا من اسطنبول زيدان
العربيه ومن شارع الاستقلال في اسطنبول